a few hours before the release of no
man's sky Sean Murray of developer hello
games today participated in a reddit AMA
I'm Dave and welcome to yet another no
man's sky news update he talks about a
lot but two big points with a pc version
delay and word that the UK studio is
already working on something new on the
subject of pc version delay it's coming
on august twelfth while the playstation
4 edition is already available the
reality is that we're still here working
on it right now there's no conspiracy
we're just racing to get all the extra
options and stuff we want ps4 comes out
tomorrow and we'll try to pretend it's a
normal workday best guess right now is 6
p.m. gmt on friday we'll keep you up to
date as we get closer as for the new
game murray was asked if you could see
hello games expanding to become a multi
game studio he said you can expect the
team to support no man's sky after
release but the team is also thinking
about new stuff there are other ideas
have got rattling around in our heads
too I think video games is just a
largely unexplored field there's very
few studios that pull off the two-game
thing but supporting one game and then
kicking of something new that's doable
right [ __ ] I just remembered we've got
another thing we're already working on
that unannounced it's a small experiment
but hopefully you might like it maybe we
can be the Johnny Depp of Game Studios
do a mixture of big stuff and dizzy
stuff so if you be exploring the
universe and no man's sky are you
excited to see what hello games does
next let us know in the comments section
below or find me on Twitter at irregular
Dave and for your no man sky news
subscribe to gamespot